and what if we're going to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the internals are the release finish
they get to play Natasha
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this was the exclusive footage that was
shown at Disney's d23 event a few months
ago as you just saw it is the intro to
each movie and TV show that is going to
be coming to phase 4 sadly there is
still a pretty long time until phase 4
begins but in the meantime I thought you
all would enjoy these intros in case
some of you haven't seen them be sure to
let me know which one is your favorite I
personally enjoyed the Hawkeye intro and
the Thor at love and thunder intro and
let me know which movie you are most
excited to see in phase 4 if you enjoyed
the video give it a like and if you want
to stay up to date on all Marvel related
content be sure to subscribe to my
channel I'm also doing some giveaways
you can find the information for them in
the description down below as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof